Hello!
Sorry!
Sorry it took so long!
Hello everybody!
Welcome back!
Hello!
Welcome to...
Duck Detective!
Duck... Detective...
Duck Detective...
I'm watching while on the toilet.
Don't tell my boss, Teehee!
Your secret is safe with me.
What the duck is going on?
There's all sorts of ducking and going on in here.
We're solving a quacking case today, everybody!
What the quack?
Detective Mint solves the case of the crying wisp.
There's no solving that one.
Yes, um...
Actually, I saw this game on Twitter.
And I was like...
Oh my gosh, I love detective games!
Good morning!
I saw this game on Twitter and I thought it looked really cute.
And actually, this is not a sponsored stream or anything But they reached out to me And they gave me a key for it, so...
Thank you!
Happy Broccoli!
Thank you for the key!
Thank you!
So...
Yeah, but...
I was wondering when I would play it, but...
Recently my throat has been pretty bad.
So...
I believe this game is voice acted.
From what I've seen.
So I think I'll be able to mostly just sit back and relax.
I think.
I saw this recently on Steam and was tempted to Supa asking you to play it.
Well, here we are.
Here we are, baby.
Thank you!
Haruka played it yesterday?
Oh, really?
Nice.
Cool, cool, cool.
Yeah, I'm so excited.
It looks so fun.
I don't know really anything about it.
Well, rather, it looks very cute.
Hope your throat feels better soon.
Thank you!
Yeah...
I think... I don't know.
Ever since I really got sick, my throat has not really recovered.
So I'm hoping that while I'm in Japan...
I won't be talking so much.
So I can hopefully...
Rest it even a little bit, you know?
Oh man, you quack me up.
Thank you!
I'm ready to duck around and find out...
The answer to this mystery!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
I'm gonna actually...
I'm gonna turn down the volume.
Even though this soundtrack is awesome.
What's the difference between sound volume and music volume?
Sound like overall volume?
That should be better.
Sound effects probably.
I'm gonna turn the voices down just a little bit too.
This so far isn't so bad.
But well, just in case.
If we can adjust anything that we need to.
If we need to.
Let's get into it though.
Because later on...
In a couple hours...
I have a meeting.
Which I'm very excited for.
Because it involves something that...
Matara and I are cooking a little bit.
For the podcast.
So...
Don't know if I can say the whole stream.
Pod squad.
But I hope you have fun with this game.
And hope to get a gift done for you.
Wait, hope to get a gift done for you.
In time for off guide.
Oh my god, Luna!
Thank you!
See you there.
So...
Yeah, let's just jump right into it then, right?
Would you like dialogue to auto advance?
No, no.
Detective mode.
Feel like a true detective.
Less information provided when incorrect.
Story mode.
A smoother experience for fledgling detectives.
More information provided when incorrect.
I don't know if you guys know this.
But...
I was once a detective.
I've thrown in the towel.
I've thrown in the hat.
I've thrown in the magnifying glass.
But...
Somewhere deep down in my soul.
Well, I am a soul.
Deep down in...
In my one soul.
Self.
Myself.
I still have it in me.
Watching you and MataMama at the same time.
Because I can't...
Well, thank you for...
For sticking around.
Thank you for watching both of us.
Mintante.
Made-tante.
Oh, made-tante is actually so good, right?
So, detective mode it is.
Life wasn't easy.
Oh my god.
Being cheesy.
I was a freshly developed detective.
Divorced duck.
Not able to pay next month's rent.
What do you mean?
Thank you.
What do you mean divorced?
Wait, hold on.
Can I change his audio?
Oh gosh.
Okay, we'll have to wait until...
He's a little loud.
I'm just gonna turn it down just a bit.
Not able to pay next month's rent.
Not that I had paid for it this month yet.
Oh no.
My brain felt foggy.
And I was trying to remember.
Where did all my money go?
I ask that to myself all the time.
And then I get idol merch in the mail.
And Metal Gear merch in the mail.
And I'm like, oh.
Divorced bro?
He's probably into divorce, man.
His voice is so good.
I had to retrace last night's steps.
Mmm.
Okay.
Deductions!
Are a vital part of a detective's work.
Find clue words by questioning persons.
Thank you!
I don't believe you.
Where is your ducktective badge?
I wasn't a duck detective.
I was a detective.
Deduction is so good.
Find clue words by questioning persons Find clue words by questioning persons and inspecting your surroundings.
Enter clue words into blank spaces to solve deductions.
The nest egg.
Probably me spent his last money on rent for blank.
Okay, cool.
Let's see.
Options again.
Voice volume a little down.
Okay, that should be better.
Sorry, I'm going to be adjusting the audio a little bit.
Duck Detective's wife took the eggs in the divorce.
Oh my god, look at him go!
Oh!
Sorry, my bad.
Oh my god, I'm playing Rocket League!
So cute!
Squidward!
Thank you for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
I finished watching Ghost Trick at work.
I've been wondering if you would play...
AI The Somnium Files in the future.
Oh, maybe!
Maybe, maybe.
I can't believe Anna actually filed the divorce papers.
Anna!
Wait, so, tab...
Oh wait, I'll go back.
We have items.
My last money is one-ish!
Not enough to take a return bus trip.
Oh no!
And where are we?
Somewhere.
Okay.
Second overdue notice.
Oh my god, is Detective okay?
I wonder at what point they start kicking people out.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is our bed!
This fresh smell...
Oh, wait, there's bread in our bed.
Oh, sweet spongy loaf.
You keep me safe at night.
Bread added to clues!
Oh no.
Um, sir?
He sighs.
Wow, she's kinda hot.
Look at that long neck of hers.
Oh my god, you know what I'm obsessed with?
I'm obsessed with pictures of those geese that saw the meteor.
And how, like, they're so, like, blue and beautiful.
And he's, like, looking up at the sky.
I'm obsessed with those pictures.
They're so cute.
And now?
She doesn't even answer my texts.
Oh my goodness.
Don't be...
I mean, you guys are divorced.
Get a grip, man.
Get a grip.
No messages.
Oh.
You haven't even cleaned up the papers on your floor.
There's loaves on the floor.
This is wasteful.
This is wasteful, wasteful.
That won't be nice.
I want to be wanted the way he wants that bread.
He is... something's going on with that bread and him.
I guess I can keep it as a souvenir.
Doesn't it say pol... police?
My new job as the duck detective isn't going any better, though.
So he quit the force to become a detective.
Well, if things keep going badly, I could always sell it online.
I don't think that's legal.
I have everything I need to solve this now.
Okay.
Me.
The duck detective spent his last money on rent for...
The duck detective.
What?
Oh, on bread.
For the duck detective.
Not my proudest moment.
Oh, my God.
He spent...
He's addicted to the bread.
The spongy loaf.
Divorce is like algebra.
You look at your ex and wonder why.
But the toast helps me to forget.
No.
You gotta...
It's not healthy for you.
Hanna!
Oh!
Moshi moshi.
I'm a different duck now.
Hanna, take him back.
I haven't had a slice of bread in weeks.
I don't believe it.
I don't believe that.
I don't believe that at all, detective.
You have to believe me.
Oh, my God.
He's so loud.
Oh.
He's toasted.
You have?
You're speaking to the duck detective?
The duck detective?
Why does he sometimes sound like Bojack?
Let's discuss this in person.
Now, be there in an hour.
His voice is out of sync and downloadable.
I'd make up to do it now.
Bearbus.
Oh, no.
Your book's gonna get soaked.
I spent more than half of my remaining cash on the bus fare.
Oh, my God.
And here I was.
In front of Bearbus' office.
Some sort of...
...run-down call center.
I don't think you have any room to talk, mister.
I'd better crack this case.
Or...
I won't even have enough money to make it better.
Let's see what else we got in here.
Oh, there's a koala.
I'm just knocking everything.
I'm a menace.
I'm a menace!
Yeah!
Litter!
Who are you?
I'm staying here until I get my money back!
Oh no!
So I found him with a hard loaf.
Bear bus?
More like scam bus!
Ooh!
Scam bus!
Ask for details.
You sound unhappy.
You bet I am!
Their stupid buses always arrive late!
The murder victim was the dodo and they have already won.
Stop!
No!
I came back from a work trip to the west and arrived here at 3 in the morning!
Oh my god!
And they don't even want to give me a refund.
How much did you pay?
Yeah, how much?
Um...
Two schmuck.
Schmuck?
That's not the point!
Where did all my money go to super tech?
Oh, thank you!
Dons, thank you.
Rico, thank you.
It's about the principle.
So true.
That is true.
It's the principle of it all, right?
What's over here?
Any evidence in the leaves?
Nope.
I think we're good.
He was going to go to therapy, but the therapist was a quack!
What's over here?
Oh, a sign.
New bus route starting in August.
Visit the scenic mountains of Sausitia.
Sausitia?
I'd always tell Anna we'd go there one day.
No, you have to stop thinking about her!
You know what?
At least she's alive.
Usually in these games, they're dead, right?
Okay, let's go inside.
Sausitia.
Bear bus... oh wait!
What's in here?
Waiting for the bus in the rain in the rain bus?
Can I trade in my 500 mint coin for Schmarks?
No!
Mint coin is priceless!
I mean, mint coin is the highest price!
What are you talking about?
One mint coin is equal to probably 500 million quadrillion bajillion macho million mint trillion Schmarks.
No, duck, don't have depression.
You're too hot.
Ducks are excellent skateboarders.
Oh my gosh.
Sephia.
Overlord.
I can already tell based on her face that the receptionist was a tough one.
She's a tough cookie.
She wouldn't make life easy for me.
Macho million.
But I had to make my way into the office.
Weren't we called here to investigate something?
Shouldn't we then...
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
She's not probably going to like that.
I like the cat little plushie right there.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
No, stay out!
It says server room.
It's locked.
Oh, so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, you know what?
I'm the duck detective.
I'm here to investigate a case.
I have to make everywhere look like my office apparently.
Okay.
Do you work here?
I just said I'm a duck detective.
Okay, the music's a little loud.
I'm going to turn it down.
Down?
No.
Well, then I can't let you in.
The rain was reminding me of a name.
Sean!
But I've been hired by someone from Bearbus.
Yeah.
Who hired you?
Um, I didn't catch their name.
That's like the most important part, detective.
Listen, buddy.
Buddy.
You better get out of here or I'll have to call security.
There's always more to people than you might think.
Hey, detective, where's your pipe?
Paige, what are you talking about?
I gave up on you.
The pipe.
Long ago.
The half pipe.
The round pipe.
What?
Daniel!
Thank you for the aqua sofa.
It's a very stressful couple of days of work from in-stream heels.
My mind has been voiced so.
Thank you.
I should take a closer look and figure out what she's about.
Okay, hold on.
Sorry.
I know I'm...
There we go.
Okay.
I think that's...
We'll just keep it all at the same level.
Okay?
Okay.
Inspection.
Use the magnifying glass to find clues and press E to uncover them.
Okay.
Oh, we got a name here.
Name tag.
Last name, Wynthime.
Oh, sorry.
Sideshoe.
Sides...
Oh, wow.
Suddenly they grow...
Ew!
They grew toes!
It's so gross.
Oh.
Cute.
Keychain, boy band, oh, k-k-k-kpop, k-k-k-kpop band.
Okay.
Oh, she grows, ew, she grows fingers.
Oh god.
Oh, she's been crying.
Tears, sad.
Oh no, her favorite boy band, her favorite, her- oh, she just announced graduation probably.
Nose, nostril, oh, it's so-
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, this is so weird, I like it though.
Oh, wait, I pressed the wrong thing, my bad.
You're still here?
I'll leave you alone.
No, but we have our information, right?
Can I- oh, I can investigate this too.
Let's see.
Oh.
Smiley, happy.
Okay.
Oh, what am I looking at?
Giraffe.
Cute.
Okay.
September 7th.
7th, today.
Cute, what does the giraffe- what does the cute giraffe have to do with it?
Wow, it's so cool how, like, everything changes when you- that's so fun.
Tomorrow is Friday.
Need to remember to collect my dry cleaning.
This is making me remember how much I miss watching you gasp.
And I think you're gonna regret this now.
It's locked.
What are you talking about?
I literally just told you you need to stay out!
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Oh, this thing.
What's this?
I swear to God, if someone steals my mug again, I'll end them.
Mug stolen threats.
Suggestions, okay.
Laura from CS is way too loud.
I can hear her keyboard.
All the way to my desk.
First name, Laura.
It's Sophie's birthday.
Hef.
Thursday.
Next!
They really should enunciate better.
Just saying.
Sophie.
First name.
Why'd they write it like that?
It looks like Hef though, right?
It looks like Hef.
I was like, what even...
What is a Hef Thursday?
Suggestions...
There's one more thing we're missing.
Oh, birthday!
Okay.
Wait, is that today?
It's her birthday!
You would want that, huh?
It's important to work out a suspect's name to crack the case.
Enter their first and last name into the slots below their portrait in the journal suspect page.
So...
What does CS stand for?
Handwriting be wild and...
Right?
I think this detective might be a quack.
Hef, Hef.
Oh, customer service!
But this is not customer service.
This is...
Oh my gosh.
Why can't I remember?
Crime scene?
Counter strike?
This is...
Yeah, receptionist.
Thank you.
Oh my goodness.
So let's go with Sophie.
Wind timer.
Okay.
Thanks, Sophie.
No one wished me a happy birthday today.
Not even my parents.
My birthday is in August.
Oh my god.
Jesus.
Shut up.
You made me feel bad for you.
I need to check my notes in the deduction section.
The deduction section.
Okay.
So...
So, deduct detective.
Nobody.
Sophie is feeling sad because nobody has remembered her birthday.
That's why she's making such a face.
I should try and cheer her up.
She's watching K-pop to make herself feel better.
Probably.
You're still here?
Sophie.
What if I just tell her your first and last name?
Good observation, Sophie Windtimer.
Get out.
Aren't you impressed I deduced your name?
Haha.
Deduction.
I'm wearing a name tag, nitwit.
Oh.
Well, it doesn't say your first name, though.
Yeah.
That part is creepy, but I'm choosing to ignore it.
It's even creepier that I know your birthday, huh?
You're still here?
Happy birthday.
I'm just here to wish you a happy birthday.
How's the audio, by the way?
I know I've been adjusting it, but let me know if it's too loud or too quiet.
I don't think it's too quiet, but...
How did you know?
Just another one of duck detectives.
Great deductions.
Huh?
Is it a long way to your heart, Sophie?
No, we're not trying to risk, Sophie.
Anyway, that was really nice of you.
No one else remembered.
Can you believe it?
Remembered.
If you know my birthday, you must have a connection to someone here.
Here's the key card to the office.
Oh, that's it?
Wow.
I don't know if that's how that works.
There, bud.
Office.
Key card.
Very good.
Thank you.
It says it's locked.
Oh, okay.
Just kidding.
Here we go.
See you later, Sophie.
Any...
By the time I leave, there won't be a dry eye in this whole building.
But not because you're sad that nobody remembered your birthday, but because you'll miss me.
The stained carpets and peeling wallpaper exuded a stench of stale coffee in a
Happy birthday, Sophie.
I got you a wedding... Why are we raising Sophie?
This is the last straw!
How do they do that with their...
How do they do that with their mouth?
Freddersen needs to be fired!
I'll see what I can do.
Freddersen, eh?
Oh, hello.
Who are you?
I'm Duck Detective.
Do you have a problem?
If you have one, just call our damn hotline.
I'm Eugene McQuacklin, the Duck Detective.
Eugene McQuacklin!
A client hired me to investigate a case.
Why didn't you just say so?
You interrogated me first!
It's time we put an end to the awful lunch theft.
Lunch theft?
All we need to fire him is some evidence for the upper management.
Okay.
I'll be in my office.
Eugene McQuacklin.
First, I had to find out who works here and what their jobs are.
I needed to find my client as well.
Yeah, who the hell hired us?
Thankfully, I remembered the piece of paper I had in my jacket.
From taking notes...
Okay.
Client note.
Alright, let's check it out.
Where's the notes?
So we have Sophie, mystery man...
Here.
I hastily wrote this before heading to the client's address.
Okay, so I guess it has some stuff that is important.
Tricky deductions might require new perspectives.
Press H to get additional guidance at any time.
Alright.
Oh, sorry.
The two desks on this side look unused.
Let's look around real quick.
Oh, sorry.
I'm sorry.
Who's this guy?
He looks really... I think he doesn't need any more cups of coffee.
It's a list of all the bus drivers.
Ooh.
The most busy driver out of all four seems to be Petrovich.
Petrovich.
Interesting.
Cute.
Oh, let's see what we got.
Bear bus.
Brezel.
Station bre...
Oh, I thought that was somebody's name.
The pretzel.
Oh, salad...
Salad...
Salad chica.
Escargot.
Okay.
Haul...
Haul in these.
Nice.
Okay.
Their buses don't go very far.
Hmm.
They're cheap.
Whose office is it?
I shouldn't go outside yet.
Oh, outside.
I need to find out who the people in this office are first.
Did I remember to write down their professions in my deductions?
Oh.
I don't think... Not yet.
Oh, sorry.
My bad.
Um...
This guy looks...
Are you okay?
Let's...
Let's observe you first.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Strained eyes.
Insomniac.
Different brand.
Own headset.
Dedicated.
Dedicated to the job.
Oh, my God.
Are you okay?
Their claws are out.
Oh, energy drink.
Bad habits.
Oh, my God.
Interesting.
Okay.
What else we got in here?
Someone...
Whitlock.
Last name Whitlock.
Just like me for real, for real.
Hottie.
Posing.
Me in...
Wait.
Password hint.
Me in sexy aliens.
What is...
What does that mean?
I don't know what I'm looking...
Oh, password.
Accessible.
Is it?
Me in...
I wonder if there are clues to her password.
I don't think I have enough information to crack it yet.
I don't think I want the information.
Sorry.
What's this?
I'm gathering everything before we talk to people.
Employee of the month.
Yippee.
Insert photo here.
Oh.
Come on.
Layout.
Lazy.
Who is making that noise?
Freddie sucks.
First name.
Freddie.
Fixed.
Rufus Sedaris.
Last name.
No, no, no.
Let's get the first name.
Rufus.
Stop with the post-its.
I'm sorry.
I'm not sure I'd feel particularly appreciated.
I got an achievement.
Complete five inspections.
The kitchen.
In here must be the crime scene.
First, I want to find out who the people in the office are.
It will make things easier in the long run.
Freddie Fazbear.
I'll need to remember to write everything down in my deductions.
No, this is Freddie after he got the divorce.
He didn't get to keep the last name.
You know?
All right.
So, we got...
We got...
All right.
This in here.
It says come in.
Oh.
Hello.
Harnessed.
The dimly lit room seemed to promise well-kept secrets and rumors.
And rumors.
What we got here?
It's a letter for an application for a promotion to senior customer service agent.
Ooh.
Signed by L.Engst.
L.Engst.
We died.
Thanks for the vibe, Gupton.
He's got kids.
Oh my god.
Look at this loving family.
Baby one.
Kids.
Identical age.
Twins.
Baby two.
How do you tell the difference?
Hair.
What else can we notice here?
What else do we notice here?
Just the twins?
What else?
Oh, a secret.
Hinge.
The safe is behind there.
Framed.
High quality.
I think so.
Secret, secrets.
We have secrets in here.
Number one dad.
We'll talk to him in a second.
Oh, what's the R?
This guy is...
Oh, Ernst.
Ernst.
So we gotta...
I gotta remember to start writing people's names down in here, right?
Oh, we don't know his first name yet.
Might be Freddy, cause he is a bear.
No, Freddy's last name was different.
Ernst.
Let's observe you.
Oh.
Angry brow.
Stir.
Okay, your ears are clean.
Oh my goodness.
He's buff.
Tie.
Expensive.
Branch manager.
Ernst.
Oh my god.
Look at these arms, beef.
Ew!
Stain.
Baby food.
Family man.
Nothing in your pants?
Your fancy little shoes?
Okay.
Alright, I guess we'll start talking with him.
How are the detective things?
The unknown things are the five gifted things.
Thank you.
It's Mr. McQuacklin.
Mr. McQuacklin, please, sir.
Right.
Apologies.
Added to clues.
Why?
Are you planning on staying in my office much longer?
Why are you doing secret things in here?
I'll have to inspect the entire premise to do my job correctly.
Well, hurry up.
Mm-hmm.
What is I?
Oh.
Question.
Was it you who called me?
No.
I never heard of you before.
That's unusual.
It's good you're here.
Since there has been some...
unrest.
Unrest, you say?
Interesting, interesting.
Well, I'll see myself out, Mr. Ernst.
Ernst.
Hmm.
Suspicious.
Yeah.
Why is...
Also, what is this stain here on the ground?
I'm hearing ghost typing and it's making me nervous.
Let's talk to this stressed little fellow.
Oh.
Just kidding.
She answers a call.
This is Fairbus.
How can I help you?
This is the third time you're calling.
I'm telling you, your ex-wife did not cancel your booking.
She looks busy.
I'll come back.
Oh.
Just kidding.
I didn't mean to press it again.
I meant to press R.
Question?
What is your relationship with Sophie Windheimer?
Excuse me for a second.
Oh, man.
I don't know how I'd survive the office without her.
Sucks that she's at the reception.
Aww.
I would have loved to have her in the office.
Interesting.
I'm back.
Yes.
Please collect your toddler from the bus station.
Toddler.
I like the way she enunciated that.
So much divorce in this game.
I know.
Right?
Are the devs okay?
No.
I'm sorry.
You can't take your 12 trombones on the bus.
What?
Can't you see I'm talking to a customer?
Oh.
It's company policy.
Nothing I can do.
She's very busy.
Do you know anything about who called me here?
Yeah.
There's a...
What are you talking about?
Listen.
I have a million more emails to answer.
And there are 50 people in the phone queue.
Where's the rest of the people?
I have worked ten days in a row including three night shifts.
And Manfred still doesn't want to give me a raise.
Manfred.
Huh?
Just leave me at peace.
So...
You have no clues for me?
Damn.
Mr. McQuacklin.
How does she do that?
Okay.
Let's go talk to our little gator friend over here.
Oh.
First of all...
What's this?
Receipt.
Expensive.
West currency.
What else we got here?
Salami?
High quality.
Salami, eh?
Spotless.
Good condition.
Takes good care of his salami.
That's a lot of salami.
Let a man have his own amount of salami.
Who's to you to say how much is a lot of salami?
Right?
Okay.
Look at all those teeth!
Laura!
Custom mug.
Wait.
Are those glasses?
Thick glasses.
Strong prescription.
Bad eyesight.
Oh my gosh.
The way the nose just like...
Claws.
Anything in your pants?
Velcro shoes.
Lame!
You guys, recently most of my shoes have become like slip-on.
Is that the same as like... It's not the same as velcro, right?
Like they have shoelaces on them but I don't need to tie them.
I can just slip them on.
Slip-on life.
Yeah.
It's so much easier when...
When you like get home and you have to take off your shoes and...
Or if you're leaving you have to just slip them on, you know?
It's so nice.
Slip-on is classy.
Okay.
We're the slip-on life, everybody.
Alright, let's talk to our little gator friend.
I'm the only one here in the operating office.
Can you imagine?
I plan all the bus routes and make sure the buses are on time.
I want a voice in Duck Detective next game.
Isn't that so cool?
Don't you have an angry customer shouting outside about the buses being late?
I...
Really?
Yes, really?
Do you have any idea who picked me to investigate?
Yeah.
No idea but I'm so happy you're here.
I don't think... I don't believe that.
I think... I sense a little tension.
I have a copy of your book.
The early bird catches the criminal.
Oh, he's a fan.
I'm not signing anything though.
Can you sign it?
No.
Maybe... later.
The fact it was a prompt.
Oh, okay.
I'll just keep the copy right here.
So you could sign it.
Later.
Yeah, later.
See you later.
So...
I guess now we head to the kitchen.
But he has a cup name that's written Laura.
Is that your cup?
In here must be the crime scene.
First, I want to find out who the people in the office are.
When you said your shoes became slip-ons, I was thinking they were regular shoes but slowly became slip-ons because your feet were shrinking.
It will make things easier.
Oh, okay.
Let's write everything down.
Okay.
First, what's... not Freddy.
What was it?
Hold on.
Rufus.
And then, Freddy sucks.
I'm so bad with names.
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
Gator is forever rejected.
Um...
Oh yes, it was Manfred, right?
Probably.
You...
Are you Laura?
And you're Rufus.
Nope.
Wrong.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh wait, it was Freddy, wasn't it?
Oh, no it's not.
Okay.
Just kidding.
Oh.
No.
Let me stop.
I don't want to take it out.
The bear is man...
Oh!
Oh, Freddy's a nickname!
Wait, how did he get...
Employee of the Month, then?
That's kind of icky.
He's the branch manager.
This doesn't make much sense.
So, Rufus... What was the last name, though?
Was it Pe...
No.
Oh gosh.
Whitlock was the girl... was that...
The sexy lamb.
Who's Angst?
Hold on.
I gotta go back and look.
Check stuff out.
This is...
Yeah, Whitlock is this lady.
I can't tell if this is Laura or not.
What if this is Laura?
Where are you anyway?
Hmm...
I shouldn't go outside.
I need to find out.
Okay.
Rufus?
Citrus?
I thought it was Freddy Citrus.
You guys are really bad with names.
Please forgive me.
Oh, it is Rufus!
You're so right.
Okay.
But didn't we try that?
Yeah, it wasn't him.
Are you Laura?
But we don't know Laura's last name, do we?
What other things do we have?
Laura from customer service is way too loud.
We got Sophie.
Bag of salami.
Oh, I can just go here.
It says there's a photo here.
And this kind of looks like a duck.
By my very astute deductions.
Imagine the aroma of Mint's gaming chair.
Bob, you didn't need to type that.
You didn't need to...
You didn't need to send that.
Oh, no.
Are you okay?
What was this button?
Oh, the bus drivers.
Busy driver out of all four seems to be Petrovich.
Petrovich is the driver.
Okay.
Let's see.
I don't think Laura has a last name though, right?
What was the angst?
Oh!
Just kidding.
When did we learn her last name?
Am I...
I don't want to just like...
Just guess around everything.
It fits her.
I don't want to guess around everything.
Intuition.
Those are the bus stops.
The promotion note.
Oh, yes, you're right.
And then she said that he refuses to give her a promotion.
Maybe if we sign his book, we'll learn his...
Oh, true.
There we go.
El angst.
Okay.
Oh, you're right.
We probably do have to sign his book so that we can learn his name.
Who do we make it out to?
All right.
Let's go talk to him.
Okay.
Oh, hello.
Hi.
How are you, Mr. Duck Detective?
I'm good.
Oh.
What do you know about Manfred Ernst?
Ernst.
I think he likes me.
He's the only one who doesn't shout at me.
Oh.
Okay.
I'm the only one here in the operating office.
Can you imagine?
Oh, God.
No wonder things don't get done.
I plan all the bus routes and make sure the buses are on time.
Isn't that so?
Don't you have an angst?
Really?
Okay.
It was this one, though, that we...
So, you...
Nope.
But I...
Oh, no.
Maybe we can't ask about the book.
Wait.
Oh, that's a salami.
Maybe we can't ask about the book anymore.
Hmm.
What do you think about Manfred Ernst?
Manfred Ernst.
Oh, he's a great guy.
I just wish I'd finally get a raise.
Oh, Laura.
Yes.
Sorry.
This is Bear Bus.
Your bus will be three hours late.
It's on the desk?
Behind him?
No, I think what I'm seeing is the little bubble above him.
I'm pretty sure it's his personal bubble.
You know?
Three hours late, baby.
Let's go.
How do I...
How do I autograph your thing?
Also, why are you using Laura's mug?
Your name is not Laura.
Oh, hello.
How are you?
Hmm.
How am I supposed to get this?
Maybe I should have...
Maybe they didn't expect me to be an asshole.
The book behind him.
Why are you yelling at me?
This book right here?
This?
Do you...
Don't you realize you're stupid now?
You yelled at me so much.
The book is behind him.
I'm sorry.
Do you feel dumb now?
There's no bubble above it.
Don't yell at me.
When you...
Maybe if you click on it some more.
But have you tried the...
Oh, it's clearly in the plant.
Yeah, it's on the other side of the table in the plant.
Obviously.
Hmm.
Well, all we have to do is wait.
All we have is Rufus or Freddy.
Freddersen.
Where did we learn that last name from?
Hmm.
Freddersen.
There's still some...
Oh, maybe we can go talk to the reception again.
Freddy Freddersen?
Let's ask her opinion on some of these people.
What can you tell me about Laura and...
Laura needs to chill out.
Dang.
I do love her.
But if she keeps living like this, she'll have a heart attack by 23.
She's not even 22.
Oh, boy.
So, do you have an idea who would have hired me?
It's about the incident, isn't it?
The incident.
I'm sorry.
Thank you for the raid.
Wait, hold on.
Leah!
Oh, my God.
Hi, Leah!
Thanks for the raid!
Oh, my gosh.
Hello.
Thanks for the raid, girl.
Mervy, thanks for the ten gifted.
Welcome, welcome.
We just kind of started this case.
It says it's locked.
Dang.
We still can't get in there.
Basically, I don't even know why I'm here.
I was gonna say I was gonna give you what has happened so far, but...
I don't even know.
Ducky, thanks for the gift.
Raymak, thanks for the five.
Thanks for the ten, Gifton.
Oh my gosh.
Implode, thanks for the five, Gifton.
Thank you for the five, Gifton.
Brandon, welcome back.
Thanks for the five, Gifton.
Rico, thanks for the five, Gifton.
Thank you guys, thank you, thank you.
Oh my goodness.
Thank you guys, thank you, thank you, thank you.
We're trying to figure out this dang crocodile's name.
But I think I missed a prompt because the game didn't expect me to be a jerk.
I'm sorry I was a jerk to you.
Please.
No, let me sign your book.
Mini Scooter.
Thank you for the fifty...
It's gone.
Cooper, thanks for the ten, Gifton.
Thank you so much.
Oh my god, is that another raid?
What is happening?
Alien Mixture, thanks for the raid.
Thank you.
What is going on?
Oh my god, our little duck detective, he's humming to himself.
Look, he even has an AFK pose.
That's so cute.
I'm the only one here in the operating office.
I play...
Don't you...
I...
Really?
Okay, also let's go ask... I guess we can go ask...
the boss man.
I guess you have to take to the bar, Gifton.
Thank you, thank you guys.
Thank you for the raids installed.
You.
What do you know about Laura Angst?
Oh, she's a fantastic employee.
Yeah, you gonna give her a raise?
She basically does the work of five people.
And she deserves the pay of five people.
That's it?
Is that why all the desks are empty?
Because...
Because there's no one else?
You guys, I'm not quite sure what to do here.
You know what...
Detective work isn't easy.
Ponder details.
The thing that bothered me in particular was...
Suspects?
I couldn't wrap my head around the suspects.
Could you hit Q for me?
Especially their...
Names.
Once I knew someone's name, I had to write it down on the suspect's page.
Only then could I interrogate suspects about their opinion of other people.
Finding out people's names was a whole other task, though.
Yeah, how am I supposed to get the gator's name?
Often, there are clues in the environment that they work in.
Okay.
Be that documents, digital or analog, or remarks of their co-workers.
It won't let me go into this room yet.
In here, must first...
It will make things...
I'll need to remember...
It won't let me go in here, and it won't let me go in here.
I shouldn't...
I need to...
Did I remember to...
Is there anything written here that I missed?
Bear bus...
No, not his name.
Oh, someone said...
What's Q?
I'm scared.
What does Q do?
My bad.
She answers the call.
This is Bear Bus.
How can I help you?
This is the third time you're calling.
I'm telling you, your ex-wife did...
She looks busy.
We did this one.
I don't know.
This is the bus drivers.
Is there anything in here on the cash payment?
Wait.
To Mr. Brandenburg.
That must be him, right?
But it wouldn't let me give it as an option.
Have I soft locked my game for real?
It's not an option.
See here.
Oh.
Oh, it's a...
Oh, it's a part of Germany.
Oh, just kidding.
Suggestion box.
If someone steals my mug again, I'll end them.
We have Laura.
I'm pretty sure Laura is...
Laura...
Oh, wait.
This is Laura.
Just kidding.
Um...
Mug on the desk.
No, there's nothing else.
This?
What you're seeing?
See, when I get close to him, it expands.
That's...
That's the bubble.
The bubble is to talk to him.
So, I'm totally lost.
What the...
You have the info you need?
I do?
You know what?
We're just gonna...
Freddy...
Anyway.
Um...
Let's ask what she thinks about Freddy.
Can you tell me more about Freddy Freddersen?
Freddy Freddersen.
Let me put you on hold while I find the route for you.
Freddy?
Did she just hiss at Freddy?
This is...
This is Leah every time she sees...
That's Leah's reaction to Freddy Fazbear.
Freddy?
Can
you imagine that?
What an incompetent waste of office space.
Hello, this is Laura again.
I checked the bus routes and found that...
Okay.
She hates Freddy.
Freddy?
No.
Okay.
What about you?
What do you think of Freddy?
Oh, never mind.
You have no opinion.
You don't care about him at all.
The voice acting in this game is so fun.
Oh god.
What?
Why don't...
Why don't you also have an opinion on Freddy?
Weird.
Okay.
Onwards to the kitchen.
Fine.
Please.
What?
Wait.
What am I missing?
Oh.
Something in here?
Okay.
Um.
Sophie, the giraffe, works as a receptionist.
The bear is Manfred as the branch manager.
Laura, the cat, works in customer service.
The crocodile called Freddy works in...
Okay.
Uh.
Operating office.
Duck approved, baby.
Now that I had worked out these names, I was ready to check out the crime scene.
The crime scene.
Let's see where that lunch got stolen from.
Then, I could finally talk to my client.
Okay.
That's a nice way to like be able to keep track of everyone.
What they do and everything.
Average of five duck per square meter?
As soon as I enter the kitchen, the comforting waft of cheap white toast entered my nostrils.
Oh, no.
No, no.
You can't relapse, detective.
I knew I had to stay strong.
Our detective is addicted to the white.
To the white bread.
The...
Not the wheat.
Not the whole grain.
The cheap white bread.
This wasn't what I was here for.
The milk toast.
Just one crumb.
No, no.
Stop eating the icing.
Ooh.
Can't you wait a couple hours?
Margaret.
It's...
If it wasn't for these pants almost bursting, I'd have this for breakfast every day.
Margaret.
Yes, yes.
And you can have it and so much more later when we're done preparing.
Why is this place a mess?
Aren't you at work?
What are you doing?
Why are you cooking?
So we have Margaret here.
Oh, just kidding.
Not yet.
Let's observe her maybe.
Oh.
Oh, God.
She's...
She's catfishing the whole office.
As soon as you...
As soon as you hold a magnifying glass up to her, the truth is revealed.
Impeccable hair, well groomed.
Whisk, baker.
Motherly.
Aw.
Why is everybody divorced in this game?
Why is literally everyone divorced?
Oops.
My bad.
Oh.
Halloween party.
Cute.
Cancel.
Oh, no.
Budget cuts.
So she's single.
Party.
Hungry?
Get your own lunch.
Where did that...
There we go.
Angry note.
Hungry.
Looking for editor.
Unpaid.
And that's it.
And some...
Some...
I think that's Laura.
And...
Sophie?
Office parties are a bad idea anyway.
They stopped doing them at the precinct after the...
Jam.
Incident.
Do tell.
Spill the tea.
Gross.
I doubt they washed their hands after leaving that greasy handprint.
What have we got in here?
Whatever this is.
Thanks for the food.
Salami bandit.
Hamprint.
Greasy.
Sharp claws.
R.S.
Margaret.
First name Margaret.
Salami bandit?
There's a real salami bandit.
A sandwich.
What else we got around here?
I don't know.
Um...
What am I missing?
Uh...
Did I...
This?
Oh!
The note.
There we go.
I thought it was the...
The sharp claws.
This must be the crime scene.
This note is curious.
Curious?
Let's observe you.
Sir?
Whoa!
Eyebrows.
Hmm...
Oh!
Toes.
Worker shoes.
Practical person.
Okay.
He's got his little toolbox.
He's the janitor.
Well, you're not...
I'm sorry.
I'm really sorry, actually.
You have a lot of work ahead of you, mister.
Oh, it's my fault.
I'm really sorry.
Sticker.
Sci-fi fan.
Oh, interesting.
He's a nerd.
All right.
Let's talk to Margaret first.
Yes, dear.
I'm Eugene McQuacklin.
Detective.
And I need to ask some questions.
A detective?
How exciting!
Everyone hide their salami.
What's the most gruesome murder you've seen?
Oh, no.
She's in the true crime podcast.
How many dead bodies have you encountered?
I could just leave.
Wait.
Five little pigs?
Teething turtles?
What does that mean?
I don't know.
Let's give her the most gruesome.
No one died.
Oh, no one died.
I investigated a case once where five little pigs robbed a bank.
Caught them red-handed and got myself an article in the Goose Times.
The Goose Times?
They called it the piggy bank case.
Did someone get shot?
Why do you...
What if Margaret is out for blood?
What?
Why?
Beaten up.
Margaret wants violence.
No.
Hmm.
Oh.
Okay.
Interesting.
What do you think about Sophie?
What do you think of Sophie Windtimer?
She doesn't have the easiest life, you know.
She just had a terrible breakup with her ex.
But don't tell anyone.
Oh.
Spilling the tea.
Margaret.
Can you tell me anything about your ex?
What do you think about Laura Engst?
She probably...
What do you...
Oh, she's such a hard-working girl.
Yeah?
I heard she secretly studies for her online bachelor's during work.
Ooh.
Well, you're not doing the work, so...
You need to keep this a secret, though.
Dang.
She's spilling everybody's secrets.
Do you know anyone here who could have hired me?
Hmm.
To be honest, everyone was quite shocked by the lunch theft.
And no one told me they've called a detective.
I don't know what's going on at all.
Okay.
Calm down, Margaret.
Sheesh.
Okay.
You're all right.
Let's add her.
Margaret Whitlock.
To the list.
And about you, sir.
Dishwasher's broken again.
Broken again.
Where are we?
Where do we live?
What's wrong with these youngsters?
Don't know how to treat things with respect.
With respect.
Why would they put the mugs in face up?
Okay.
That's really devilish.
That's really devilish, actually.
That is so evil.
Okay.
What do you think of Mar...
What do you think of Margaret?
What is your relationship with Margaret Whitlock?
Yeah.
Ah, she's a true sweetheart.
Ahem...
We have our weekly mahjong evenings.
Mah... mahjong evenings?
Okay.
What...
I'm just joking.
Just playing Mahjong.
Oh my gosh, is that the new...
Forget Netflix and chill, everybody.
Mahjong evenings is the new hot stuff.
Ernst.
Does anybody enjoy Freddy Ferderson's company?
Huh?
It's over for me.
Oh, he doesn't like him, okay.
Who hired us?
Is that so?
Why is there nobody who...
What?
You were doing just fine.
I don't need no messing about our business around here.
Okay, suspicious sir.
Why wouldn't you want a detective to solve the mystery lunch disappearance?
Huh?
Interesting, interesting, interesting.
Let's see.
So, are you Rufus?
He's our employee of the month.
The janitor.
And then we have one more character.
This must be the person that hired us.
Where else can we go?
I guess we can ask other people about these characters.
Such as Freddy.
What do you think of Margaret?
What can you tell me about Margaret Whitlock?
She gets really angry with me when I don't return mugs to the kitchen.
Yeah, you have four right there and one in your hand.
Um.
Why don't you just return them?
Yeah.
I do.
Just not every day.
This guy is just so gross.
There's bananas.
Why don't you just pick up your stuff?
Me?
No.
Don't be messy, you guys.
Don't be messy.
This guy.
For real.
I forgot, I think, to ask Margaret what her name is.
What her opinion is of Rufus.
Not me.
No!
Oh, here we go.
Are you getting along with Rufus Sedaris?
Uh-huh.
You know, the two of us are from the older generation.
Oh, but you got...
You're young at heart.
You got that young spunk, don't you, Margaret?
Which means we understand each other well.
Uh-huh.
He is quite harsh towards the younger ones, though.
Interesting.
He's a real respect your elders kind of guy.
I see.
She's strong at heart.
Oh, yeah.
That's right.
We got to figure out a way into her computer.
What about you, sir?
Rufus.
What is Rufus Sedaris like?
Sedaris.
Not the greatest janitor.
Then how did he get...
Then how did he get Employee of the Month, huh?
He came with the building.
Oh.
That's it?
That's it.
Okay.
Poor Laura is so underappreciated at this place.
Are you okay, Laura?
Do you need...
Do you need a second?
So the password hint was me in sexy aliens, which...
Still...
Look at this.
This is like when grandma discovers filters, Snapchat filters and stuff.
Me in sexy aliens.
I'm so...
Margaret got some dubious activities.
Yeah.
Someone did like sci-fi.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Surprise.
Let's see.
What do we have here?
The client.
Blank hired the duck detective because his her blank was blank.
The lunch was stolen by a coworker known as the salami bandit.
We know that a little bit.
More suspects.
Oh.
Margaret is the sheep who works in customer service.
Penguin is the salami bandit.
Rufus works as the janitor.
Buffalo.
Okay.
Let's go outside.
Maybe we'll find him out there.
Here we go.
Yeah.
I knew that the penguin is a Star Trek fan.
So...
Oh, there he is.
So he'll probably have the answer.
The cold air ruffled my feathers and I wondered what kind of sorry soul was standing all alone in the rain.
I need the soundtrack for this game.
It's so good.
I'm sorry.
What else?
Is anything over here?
No.
What's this note?
How mysterious.
I want to read it.
Why are there post-it notes everywhere?
What's this?
Someone left their bag here.
Ugh.
It's full of dirty gym clothes.
Nice.
Duffle bag.
Get.
For my own personal collection, of course.
Let's see.
Oh.
Well...
Well-proportioned nose.
Handsome.
Look at the top of his head.
So neat and clean.
Oh.
Hands and pockets.
Bad manners.
What?
That's bad manners?
Is it really?
Hands and pockets are...
Oh.
Boris.
Embroidery.
First name.
Boris.
New character.
Let's go.
Hey, man.
This isn't the bus stop.
You'll have to walk south to the central bus station.
Everybody's got an accent.
What?
I'm not here to take a bus.
Yeah.
I'm a detective.
Hey, man.
It's cold out, but if I go inside, I have to face Sophie.
Is that your ex?
What's your relationship?
What do you think of Sophie Windheimer?
Yeah.
He sucks.
Man, I wish she'd let me talk to her.
What does that mean?
Do you like Freddy Fredersen?
It's rude in certain situations.
Really.
Is it?
He's a pretty funny dude.
Loves to rant about detective novels.
Okay.
What do you know about Rufus Sedaris?
I don't think he likes me very much, to be honest.
But then, it doesn't feel like he likes anyone at this office.
You're rude.
You're a rude youngster.
Except for Margaret, I guess.
Do you think they have a thing going on?
Gossip.
I don't work here.
I thought you were a detective.
What?
Okay.
I'm investigating a case here at Bearbus.
Oh.
Do you mean the lunch that got stolen?
Yes.
Exactly.
Do you know who called me?
Nah.
Too busy minding my own business.
Uh-huh.
I don't talk much with the customer service folks.
What?
So, what?
Are you a bus driver?
Do you know anything about this bag?
Oh.
Mahjonging all over the place?
You.
What is it?
He's going to ride it.
He's going to run her.
Oh gosh.
East, West, North, South.
Oh man.
It's really strange.
Things in it disappeared.
Rritty!
He's reaching all over the place.
Bala!
Thanks for the donut.
Thank ya.
And others appeared.
Very suspicious.
What are you going to do?
It's true.
Why is everybody so round?
Nobody is giving a solid answer.
Oh.
Okay.
So typically they each have like a... what's the word?
A two-dialogue.
So he is our main bus driver.
Boris Petrovich.
Ducks in a row.
Fill out all suspects' names.
Let's go!
And here.
Oh.
More suspects.
Boris is the buffalo.
Is a bus driver.
Awesome.
Uh-huh.
The only person we haven't been able to talk to.
That could tell us if they hired us is Laura.
Because she's been so busy.
So I wonder if it's her.
Nice!
So it was Laura who called me.
I needed to discuss the case with her.
You're my client?
Why didn't you tell me?
Yeah!
Can I put you on hold for a second?
What?
You should have told me you're the duck detective.
I did say.
I'm a duck.
I'm wearing a trench coat.
So is Freddy getting fired or what?
Ooh.
I'm working on it.
Dang.
It can't be that hard.
Sorry I'm back.
Yes, let me walk you through the booking process.
It was time that I found out what happened with the lunch theft.
And what they were planning in the kitchen.
In the kitchen.
Blank is planning a blank blank blank for blank.
Margaret is planning a surprise birthday party for Sophie.
Margaret was planning a surprise birthday party for Sophie.
Yes.
I see.
She didn't actually forget her birthday.
Elementary, my dear wisp.
How did you know?
I'm telling you.
I'm a duck detective.
Oh yeah, there's other stuff here too.
Let's see.
The culprit.
Blank is being blank by blank because Blank picked up the blank blank.
So and so is being framed by blank because Blank picked up the blank blank.
The wrong mug.
I wonder.
I wonder if Freddy is being framed by someone because...
Wait.
Hmm.
We still don't know this one quite yet.
I need to get into her computer.
So I can see any evidence she has in her emails.
Noon night sign.
Welcome to Bamboo Shep.
Thank you.
Let's see.
Do you know whose bag this is?
Isn't that Freddy's?
Freddy's bag.
So it was swapped out.
He has the bag.
His bag is actually the bag with the...
With the gym clothes.
But they swapped it out.
Do you know anything about this bag?
Why are you going around pushing bags into people's faces?
What's that awful smell?
Embrace it.
It's dirty gym clothes.
The bag of 87.
Oh, I doubt they want...
Yeah.
Okay.
We looked in through there.
Oh, that's so sweet that she's actually doing surprise party though.
Oh, let's ask Freddy about his bag.
Is this your bag?
Huh?
No.
Mine's over there.
The one with all the salami?
You know, the salami bandit?
Yeah.
Why do you need so much salami?
It's not mine.
It was just there.
A really nice surprise.
Oh.
Nice.
Do you get along with Boris Petrovich?
He's a chill guy.
I take the bus sometimes to go to bouldering conventions.
And then we get to chat.
Bouldering conventions?
What is bouldering?
Is that climbing or...
Bouldering.
Oh, Freddy.
Rock climbing?
Okay.
It's climbing without a harness.
Yo, Freddy goes hard.
Freddy's a bit of an adrenaline junkie.
What kind of a person is Boris Petrovich?
Ugh.
I don't know what I saw in him.
They were.
That is their ex.
I mean, I guess he's good looking.
But...
Hahaha.
Good evening, Officer Brent.
How are you doing?
I'm great.
Thank you.
My god.
Is he boring?
Oh.
How are you getting on with Margaret Whitlock?
She's sweet and all.
But...
But?
She can't keep her mouth shut.
Okay.
That is so true.
It seems like the office knows more about my personal life than me.
Than me.
The office.
I wonder how this guy is doing out here.
I can't leave now.
Oh.
I need to solve...
Just kidding.
Boris is into tall chicks.
Spaced.
Okay.
Let's see.
Let's go on in.
What can you tell me about Boris Petrovich?
He's... not the most reliable worker.
But it's difficult finding replacements nowadays.
Mm-hmm.
We still don't know what's behind his...
This, you know?
What are you doing with my family's portrait?
Oh!
Sorry.
It's just admiring your lovely...
Your lovely life.
You know?
Just admiring your lovely... wife.
But PCs are.
They only have that surprising.
How do I get in?
Accessible.
Maybe we don't access it.
Maybe...
Someone else accessed it because they knew the hint.
A.K.A.
our little penguin friend over here.
Maybe he got onto our computer to do something.
With the note.
Salami.
And it's the sharp claws.
That makes me think that they're framing.
Freddy.
You know?
Well, I mean...
They are framing Freddy.
Because...
They gave him the salami.
So...
Wait a minute.
It already wants me to...
Okay.
Oh...
Um...
It already...
It already wants me to solve it.
Oh...
Okay.
Um...
Freddy...
Is being framed by...
Um...
Uh...
By...
Laurel?
Because...
Freddy...
Two or fewer things are wrong.
You have all the information.
Just think back.
Think mug equals lunch.
No.
Well, he had the...
She was so mad about him getting...
Grabbing her mug all the time.
Right?
Mug?
Not back?
No.
I don't think it was the wrong bag.
Right?
Or is it the wrong...
Okay.
Wait.
It's so clean.
Do you know who else was clean?
Margaret.
She was also clean.
And divorced.
Hmm...
Yeah.
His gym bag...
Or his dirty clothes...
Yeah.
So, Freddy picked up the wrong bag.
I love how Bearbus...
He's just being framed by Bearbus.
Everybody is out to get him.
Everybody hates Freddy.
Everybody wants Freddy out of here.
No...
Why am I blanking out on this so much?
Okay.
Hold on.
I think maybe because I'm...
Okay.
There's Margaret's sandwich.
Why is it wide open like that?
R.S.
is...
Is...
The janitor.
What's that sound?
And then...
This is...
Laura's...
Oh, they're brewing coffee.
Oh, I hear it.
Yeah, you're right.
Why am I blanking so much with this?
Hmm...
So, maybe Freddy is being framed by...
Um...
It wouldn't be Manfred, right?
But...
Would it be...
Not the wrong bat.
Huh?
Ugh...
They...
Hmm...
Use your brain, Mint.
I don't know.
I have no brain cells right now.
Just look through the names.
I don't think it's Boris.
Is it Rufus?
Email bag X.
I mean, he picked up the wrong X.
Unless it's Manfred's lunch.
It's available...
The game is like...
By the way, this is so wrong.
Just please give up.
Okay.
I think it...
I think it is...
The bag, then.
Time for...
Wait, what happens if I do...
Oh, it doesn't change anything.
We're fine.
Why bag?
You are...
What?
You were about...
You were...
You were hired to solve the missing lunch.
Then what does the bag have to do with it?
I think they just switched out the bags, right?
So, Freddy is being framed...
By...
Is it Margaret?
You evil, conniving sheep.
What do you carry lunches in?
A bag.
Or your hands.
I don't know.
Why am I?
Why can't I figure this out?
Am I stupid?
I think about the lunch was stolen by who...
Well, I don't know.
Who would have won it?
Because each person in here are...
He has his own lunch.
Margaret has her own lunch.
This is...
Well, I'm assuming it's Laura's lunch.
I'm assuming it's Laura's lunch, but what if it's not?
Is it...
Try looking through all the names, nouns, and choices.
Suspicious.
I think it's framed.
By...
The salami bandit.
Oh wait.
Freddie!
Framed by Freddie!
Freddie is being framed by Freddie because Freddie picked up the wrong...
And who didn't like who, right?
Bad manners.
Maybe Boris ate the lunch.
Who knows?
She also has bad habits.
Lame.
So sad.
But he has bad eyesight.
So he picked the wrong thing, right?
On accident, probably.
It was Freddie all this time.
Don't trust anybody.
Not even.
Not even yourself.
So maybe he is being framed by Boris.
One day he'll complete this puzzle.
It's because I did the other one so quickly.
Laura does hate Freddie.
Look at the pits at this point.
It's painful.
I'm sorry!
Laura wants...
I tried though!
I tried Laura!
Freddie is being framed by Laura.
But I don't...
It didn't work!
What?
Keep cooking but don't listen to the haters.
At this point, I have no idea.
At this point, I'm so confused.
If it's the bag.
If it's a...
If it's a bag.
If it's a mug.
If it's a salami.
If it's a lunch.
I have no idea!
Is it because the salami man picked the wrong lunch?
Nope.
Three things must be wrong.
So no.
Oh, whoops.
Wait.
Bag.
You gotta think like a dog.
I'm not a dog!
I'm a ghost!
This is a twist.
The double cross is...
This is a hoop!
The dog did it.
Oh, did we try clicking on that book on the desk some more?
Is this all because I didn't sign the book?
Dang it.
Call the colonel.
I don't think the hints are literally gonna give anything though.
Detective work isn't easy.
Ponder details.
The thing that bothered me in particular was...
The culprit.
To figure out the situation about the culprit, I had to consider...
Important objects.
What objects stood out in this case?
I had to check again which objects the people involved interacted with.
I had to take into consideration who the note in the fridge was signed by.
And why they decided to take action.
I had a feeling something bigger was going on than meets the eye.
Thanks, Ducktective.
Clearly Ocelot must be responsible.
Wait, so...
Um...
So who signed the note?
That's a great question.
This little...
This... this...
I thought... honestly...
If you had told me it was like a poorly drawn sun...
Like a sunrise, I would have believed you.
But it's a claw.
I thought it was a sun at first.
So who has the claws?
Freddy's got claws.
Manfred's got claws.
Doesn't he?
I have to go back and look at everybody's claws.
She's got divorced.
This guy has no hand... wait...
He's got claws!
Everybody's got claws, I think.
Oops, sorry.
I pressed the wrong button.
Or did I?
Maybe I pressed the right button.
Oh yeah, this is baby food.
I was like, wait, he's got evidence on him.
I'm so glad...
Vint hasn't realized that I'm Freddy.
Oh, this way.
Hold on.
Laura, let me see your hands.
Oh, those are really claw-like.
But why would she steal...
See, that's...
Why would... I mean...
She's stealing your old lunch.
But she's also trying to get this guy fired.
She's like, fire Freddy, fire Freddy.
She hates him.
Oh, that's a caps lock.
So I feel like it's gotta be Laura, right?
Because...
Because he picked up the mug.
I feel like that is correct.
That Freddy is being framed by Laura because Freddy took her mug again.
But I don't understand why it's wrong.
What Freddy do?
He...
He took her mug.
And she said, I hate when people take my mug.
It's obvious.
The duck detective.
But...
Planted the evidence himself.
Then gave himself amnesia.
The perfect crime.
You're too far ahead.
What do you mean?
Change the name?
The salami bandit is being...
I
feel like it has to be...
Like, being suspicious.
By who?
I don't know.
That doesn't make any sense.
Someone is being suspicious...
By someone?
That doesn't make any sense.
The answer is more simple than you think.
What?
Just tell me at this point.
Positively, these are the five gifts.
Oh my god.
Now it's three things wrong.
I hope the...
The devs are not watching this right now.
How am I overcomplicating it?
Please, I have a meeting in an hour.
Oh my god.
There's only so many things.
I feel like framed makes the most sense, right?
The duck detective is being framed.
Freddy is the correct thing here.
Suspicious...
It's actually a good sound.
I don't know how to simplify this anymore than I already have.
I don't know how to simplify this more than I already have.
This is why I gave up the life of being a detective.
I'm gonna go get more tea.
I'll be right back.
I'm gonna just go get more tea.
I'm back.
Okay.
Thank you.
Oh.
Wrong thing.
This too.
Did you catch any fish?
I got a whole boatload.
A whole boatload.
Okay.
Back to my...
Sorry.
Tara just messaged me something really stupid.
It was the Colonel Mustard in the library with the candlestick.
I knew it.
Oh my gosh.
Will the fish fit in your hat?
No.
They're really huge fish.
Why would they fit in my hat?
That makes no sense.
Okay.
So is it?
The salami bandit?
Picked up...
No.
Is he being framed maybe by the salami bandit?
Oh god.
Oh my god.
That's what they're talking about.
Oh.
I'm letting myself...
Oh, you were.
A salami bandit.
Sure.
It's...
He's a salami bandit.
Like...
Oh...
He can't
be a salami bandit.
He's a salami bandit.
Oh, I knew it.
It's like his uniform was...
Yeah.
Salami bandit.
THAT'S WHAT I SAID!
The bandit!
Oh, I almost said the sausage bandit.
I can't even remember.
Why didn't you just say, hey, that's my bag instead?
Why didn't the salami bandit just say, hey man, that's my bag.
Oh my god.
Thank you for that.
Super detective, you're a mystery.
Your investigative skills are second to many, first to none.
Oh god.
Yeah, resting your voice, by the way.
Man, my throat has been really bad lately.
Also, I wonder why.
Surprise!
Uh, no way.
This is... all for me?
Huh?
A letter?
It's more sala- oh!
Oh no.
Salami?
What a terrible present.
No, you silly idiot!
The real present got stolen and switched for salami!
Fuck it.
The salami bag!
I'll get you!
That thing's for the five gifted.
I saw an awful lot of high grade salami in Fredderson's bag.
That's really suspicious that you would immediately name him.
You screamed about Freddy being framed just now, right as I was rewatching the part from yesterday's podcast episode, where you started yelling, Freddy, his name is Freddy!
And now there's no question who the perpetrator is!
I've been telling you all along, we can't trust Fredderson!
What are you talking about?
She's crying!
So, Sophie received the following presents.
Anyway, oh wait.
Oh, we did all of this.
Just kidding.
The moment you said surprise, my browser decided to reset itself.
Haunted.
Yeah!
Who messes with someone's birthday?
Let's see.
A plushie.
Ooh!
Limited edition.
Where did we see the cat plushie before?
It's a heart-shaped necklace.
Looks tacky.
That's probably Boris.
Wait, this is the sexy alien book, right?
Sexy aliens won my number!
Captain Brightbeak stared deep into the alien's eyes.
There were twelve of them, and they were red.
The eyes, not the aliens.
All the aliens were blue, and there were forty-three.
All of them wore shiny metal armor, which shined like something shiny made of curved metal.
The lead alien stepped forward.
Captain Brightbeak could tell it was the lead alien because it was the one which stepped forward.
It was also the most beautiful, the only one with purple eyes.
It made a noise that sounded a bit like talking.
From a hole that looked a bit like a pretty lady's mouth.
The translation device the captain had invented word into action, translating the words into words he could understand.
Hey, you look cute.
A mechanical voice whispered into his ear.
Can I get your number?
Why is that page 252?
621 total pages!
Also, that name...
Isn't that Rufus' last name?
Or am I stupid?
Questionable title.
Adult novel.
Oh.
Oh god.
What did I just read?
Yeah, I want some more.
Buong... Buong... Buong... Buongiorno, everyone.
Everyone.
Not just Sophie.
Weird message.
Also, E is underlined.
B...
Quite unbelievable, I entered the office really easily.
Lol.
Sayonara, edgelords.
I think
it's Boris gave the necklace and then something got stolen.
Let's talk.
Do you think she liked my present?
I mean, now she's crying, but I think I saw a sparkle in her eyes when she opened mine.
I should really get back to work.
Yeah.
Oh, whoops.
Depressed.
Do you think I...
Oh, wait.
I should...
It's a...
Oh, it's R.
My bad.
This one.
Can you tell me something about this letter?
About this letter?
Sophie won't even talk to me about it.
I don't know what to do.
And she won't talk to me either.
Or her.
Okay.
Let's keep going.
Let's ask other...
Is this Hades too?
What do you have to say about it, huh?
So...
What happens to the cake now?
Rufus.
Oh my gosh.
I almost just spilled something.
Rufus.
What do you think about this letter?
Hmm.
Um...
People don't know how to write letters by hand anymore.
This guy...
Back in my day.
Oh, cause he's an author.
Cause he's an author.
He's all...
He's all like...
It's gotta be perfect, you know?
Okay.
They...
They really think I've done it.
Detective, you have to help me.
You...
You know it wasn't me, right?
What's bag mean?
Did you not think it was strange that your bag was full of salami?
Uh...
I don't know.
I thought someone gave me a salami surprise.
That's...
You know what?
That's a typical...
You know.
Pass his life and boob his hometown.
Don't change, man.
Thanks for the super chat, Len.
I'll eat salami sandwiches for breakfast, lunch and dinner from now on.
That's not the point.
Okay.
Doofus.
I wanna get into the server room.
Wait.
Maybe we can get in now.
Cause no one's here.
It says it's locked.
Dang.
Let's go.
She likes the cats though.
So I'm guessing that one's from...
And you know...
Uh...
Laura is a cat.
So...
I'm guessing that one's from her.
And then Boris.
And then...
But who did it get stolen?
Who's got stolen?
Unless...
It's all...
Freddy's got stolen.
Probably.
Cause they're framing him, right?
Do you know anything about this letter?
Well, it's obviously a cheap prank by Fredderson.
Hopefully he would find this funny.
I'm guessing you're ready to present legal evidence of Fredderson's misconducts.
It wasn't Fredderson.
Everything is pointing towards him.
I will present the true culprit soon enough.
Soon enough.
Well, I don't really care how long it takes.
This will be Fredderson's last day.
Oh!
What?
Everybody...
Everybody wants him fired!
Ducks are 70% more likely.
Also, yeah.
Someone said that her...
That Laura's computer is free.
What's this one, though?
This folder says, manual for CS agents.
How and when to create vouchers correctly?
I'm falling asleep just reading the title.
I think it's great reading.
All right.
Let's see.
What do we got here?
Oh!
Sophie.
Chat friends.
Okay.
What are they talking about?
But... something... returned.
But they're sexy now.
Bye now.
The aliens have returned!
But they're sexy now.
OMG.
Lol.
Is he serious?
What a dumb pen name.
Hahaha.
It's just his name backwards.
Complaints.
Can the OO please clean their desk?
I can smell it.
Until here.
She's a complainer.
Jeebus.
Crossed book on the map.
Bishop.
Thank you!
So she's a complainer, eh?
You definitely don't want to be Laura's enemy.
Okay.
So...
Laura gave the plushie.
Rufus gave the book.
And maybe...
Oh.
Uh...
Something got stolen.
Books?
Letters?
Necklaces?
Plushies?
Nothing got stolen.
Everybody...
So...
Nothing got stolen after all.
Okay.
It seemed that the salami present was intentional.
Hmm.
Very interesting indeed.
It's a conspiracy.
Yeah, they say salami banned it, but people's stuff was there.
Hmm.
When can I get...
Sexy alien...
Alien...
Sexy aliens want my number two.
When can I get that?
Okay.
I'll...
I'll comfort her.
It'll be okay.
You have the duck detective here to figure everything out.
What can you possibly do?
I'm a detective.
Leave me alone.
Okay.
Sorry, ma'am.
Um...
I'm sorry.
Is there something in here that we're...
Oh.
The message.
Receive the blank.
Oh wait!
We have to talk to Boris.
I don't know where he is.
Oh my goodness.
Completely forgot about him.
And...
Oh yeah.
There's also Margaret's PC.
So...
Now...
Blue...
Skinned alien.
Me and sexy alien.
Blue skinned alien?
Oh no...
Purple.
Red-eyed alien.
Shiny.
Armored.
Wait, wait!
Purple-eyed alien.
Nice!
She's the main alien!
Let's see what secrets she has on her computer.
Ha ha ha!
Secrets!
Let's see.
West VPN?
Secret cake recipes?
Never gonna give you up dot wave?
Bus fare internal vouchers for CS agents.
Three hour delay compensation.
Booked on next bus.
A vacation, eh?
Planned trip.
Interesting.
Delete everything!
What?
Cutie!
Illegal activity?
But the alien... it has to be Rufus.
This makes me never want to work in an office.
This is exactly what it's like, even.
Who is this person she's messaging?
Oh, I think I have a clone.
Oh wait, we've already talked about it.
Okay, let's go see what Boris thinks.
We haven't talked to him.
Oh, what's this now?
Customs procedures for passengers entering from the west border.
Import.
Allowed goods.
Personal items worth less than 500 shmark.
Notify the local police about suspicious activity.
Prohibited goods.
Oh, there better not be salami on this list.
Weapons.
Gun.
Scary.
Over 10 trombones.
Meat!
Potatoes.
Books not in the interests of the eastern states.
Plants.
Luggage will be checked at the bus station.
For more information, visit this place's customs.
But also, books not in the interests of the...
Uh-oh.
If they're going on a trip...
He can't... he has his books...
What do they have against potatoes?
Potato famine is not a joke.
Maybe it was too romantic.
Did Sophie ask about me?
Uh...
What do you think, guys?
Should we give this guy some follow-ups?
Should we give this guy some false hope or...
Should we... should we give this guy some false hope or...
Do you think, uh...
No?
Nah, he's rude.
True.
It did say it looked cheap.
It did say that.
Okay, so yeah, we definitely knew that.
Let's see.
So...
Let's...
I'm just gonna put Sophie received a...
Romantic...
Book that contained...
A...
Scary...
Message.
Or...
Margaret received a ro... a...
A message.
A contained...
I don't know.
Actually...
Well, I was gonna say message.
Like, cause they were messaging online, but...
The book is contained a scary message, you guys.
Scary aliens.
It contained a scary salami.
The message.
So my...
Uh...
Sophie...
Received a...
Nice...
Well...
A nice salami.
That contained a scary salami.
Oh no!
It wasn't a nice salami after all.
It was a scary salami.
Wait, hold on.
Let's go back inside.
I don't wanna be...
You know...
Doing my work in the rain after all.
Let's go in here.
So would it be this?
B.E.
I don't think anybody's initials are that, are they?
Boris?
It's a B.
It's salamis all the way down.
Salami, salami, salami.
So what is the message?
Is it...
Is it this message?
Or is it...
I think it's a...
Oh no, here we go again.
It's this message though, right?
That's what I'm assuming.
So, Margaret received a...
So it's the message in the box, not the message she received on the computer?
In the box.
Oh, okay.
Sophie received a nice salami.
A scary message.
That contained...
A nice salami.
Take a closer look at the note.
Okay.
Well, it said like...
It was like a...
It was like...
A cocky message.
It was like a...
Yeah, a cocky attitude.
A weird message.
Quite unbelievable.
I entered the office really easily.
But also, why is this whole part blank?
Why did they write it like that?
A cocky salami.
This is the content I come here for.
Also, rip your throat.
Oh, wait.
I just wanted to say that your laugh is extremely charming.
I feel happy while listening to your laugh.
Thank you.
Your brain cell...
Oh my god.
They're kind of behind.
Oh my goodness, sorry.
The brain cell you took with you after leaving heaven...
Really put in the work...
Okay.
So she received...
None of these are strange.
A silly message.
It's not a romantic message.
She received a...
A silly salami.
Letter.
A scary letter.
Not scary.
It's not a nice letter though.
It's not a silly letter either.
Scary letter.
That contained...
I'm so confused by these letters.
These adjectives.
A romantic salami...
I think romantic salami sounds really correct.
Thank you.
My voice hasn't really recovered.
Also, a mental breakdown and girly screeches.
Maybe in reverse.
Contained a...
nice salami.
Hmm.
A silly salami?
Oh, maybe silly letter?
Scary salami?
I think B.E.
is Bema Emmerich.
What's wrong with B.E.?
Is there a present in here?
No, there's no present.
There's nothing in here that says she received a present, you know?
She received salami that contained a letter.
I guess?
What else is in here?
Wait, wait, wait!
A silly letter that contained a scary...
Message!
Why is it a silly letter though?
Why is it a silly letter?
OK.
It was a letter that contained a message.
Got it, got it, got it.
Oh no, there's more.
Blank are being blanked, blanked from blank.
Books are being illegally imported from...
Wait.
Where was the...
Oh no, not this one.
The vacation?
Brazil?
I don't think there was a Brazil.
Brazil!
Bretzel.
It's from Bretzel.
Unless it's not books, unless it's...
Salamis.
That explains all the high-grade salami.
Yeah, because it was on the letter.
Or on the receipt, right?
We just needed to find out who was behind this.
The mystery of the salami bandits was slowly getting unraveled.
It was on the receipt.
Western goods are prohibited from entering and being sold in the East.
Yeah.
This is why the salami bandits decided to make a business.
Out of buying high-grade salami in the West.
And smuggling it to the East.
And that's why you didn't want him to take his bag.
And selling it at a high profit.
And then they're gonna go on vacation with the money.
Also, for some reason, Sophie received a letter from the salami bandits.
Because they were making fun of his book.
And had a hidden, threatening message.
Wait.
Why are all the letters there?
They look different.
This was serious.
I had to question all of the employees.
All of them.
They were making fun of his book and so they're upset.
Thanks for coming, everyone.
Well, everyone except for Sophie.
Where is she?
Slacking off.
Playing on her computer phone.
Computer phone.
She's having problems with her family.
She was at her desk and said she needed a moment.
No.
Romani.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I will start then regardless.
I have made my deductions.
Yes.
And drawn some serious conclusions.
Serious conclusions.
Finally.
Is Freddy getting fired then?
Oh gosh.
Freddy's not getting fired, you guys.
This is pretty bad.
Laura's gonna be so mad at me.
Who is the murderer?
I...
What?
No one died.
I went to check out hives for the first time since breeding them since the washboards and the roads out there were bad enough to where they rattled my windshield.
Wait.
Are you okay?
Just wanted to let...
All are fine.
Oh.
Glad they're okay.
I'm getting frayed.
I'm telling you.
You are.
But not by Laura who I originally thought.
Want a load of bologna?
No, actually.
Salami.
He is right, actually.
He is getting frayed.
Laura is also the shift Yanike.
No way.
Why anyone bother?
That is the question, isn't it?
Why would anyone bother?
Get to the point.
It's through my observations that I uncovered.
I uncovered...
A conspiracy.
Yeah.
I mean yes.
I did uncover that.
Oh.
Oh, gasp.
I told Otacon I don't believe in the supernatural, but now I do.
Love the voice acting in this.
It's so good.
Oh, no, no, sir.
Stop right there.
Oh, or...
I'm a certified private investigator and...
It's okay.
Just tell us what you know.
Maybe the salami we made was the friends along the way or something.
Salami is being smuggled from South Sitia using your very own buses.
What's going on?
Okay, this is going too far.
I really have more important things to do.
Everyone's leaving!
Now that is really scandalous.
Does that mean we're losing our jobs?
Uh... maybe.
Why is everybody leaving?
Listen, everybody.
It's really important that no one leaves the premises.
I need to get back to work.
Wait a second!
Everybody's leaving?
Oh...
I'm still here, Mr. Duck Detective.
Nobody cares!
Yeah...
Um...
I guess we'll just continue our illegal activities.
Wait, whose phone is this?
Oh?
K.T.
Senjoyer.
Oh, K.T.S.
K.T.S.
Enjoyer!
Almost dead.
Are your parents still angry at you?
Min-tenjoyer.
Wow.
This is nonsensical.
Did she get kidnapped?
This is curious.
I think she got kidnapped, you guys.
Why would she write like this?
Uh oh.
Someone forgot their phone.
Oh, the music changed and everything.
It's kinda fun.
This is getting intense, isn't it?
I don't think so.
Lonely added the clues!
This game is targeting me!
What do you want me to do?
Decide for messages?
Talk someone into telling us the truth?
Follow people around?
I'm pretty good at that.
Just stay here.
Yeah.
Like this?
You're doing great.
Okay.
Everybody went back to work.
Which is really great.
Sophie's probably kidnapped.
Oh.
They seem a bit worried.
Oh my god, there's a mess of a scene here.
I think she really was kidnapped.
Or it was me.
Uh-oh.
This is...
Oh!
The cat is on the ground!
Um...
Sophie left!
And she left a note on the desk.
Oh, she did now.
Did she?
What's this?
Let's... the last dialed number on this phone is 03-05...
Missed some streams.
How did this become a...
1777.
Oh my gosh!
They just doxxed my phone number!
What's this?
Unknown number.
Anymore.
I'll tell them everything.
Don't.
Fight.
You blocked this number.
Click here to unblock.
Interesting.
Am I the asshole for expecting my coworkers to remember my birthday?
It's my 20F birthday.
I'm so happy.
Today.
And no one congratulated me.
I don't need much, but at least a handwritten card would have been nice.
I can't believe she complained about this online.
She's a...
She went to Reddit for it.
It's crazy.
Wait, where's the note?
Oh, here it is.
That's it.
I quit.
Sudden news.
You'll never see me again.
Wait a second.
Sophie Windthimer.
This is not her.
This is the bandit's handwriting.
Sophie.
Let her off.
Uh-oh.
What a dramatic turn.
I should keep this as evidence.
Better late.
Get.
She left?
Just like this?
Just like this.
Maybe she's at home.
Should I look for her?
Did you read Sophie's letter?
I did.
Something's off.
Uh-huh.
Something's different.
The handwriting.
The handwriting is different.
This is the note Sophie left.
Can you tell me more about it?
And you know who was the first person to leave?
Sophie.
The penguin.
He had all the time.
He was the first person to leave the room.
It's totally him.
It doesn't make sense at all that she'd just suddenly leave.
She definitely needs the money.
And she would have told me.
I'm her friend.
Uh-huh.
No, the bear was...
No, it was definitely the penguin.
Would you ever do a stream where you just read Am I the Asshole post while playing Minecraft?
Sure.
Oh, we can also check out his computer.
Hey, Eugene McQuacklin.
Throw bread to the fine beak of lady justice.
That's me.
Stalking.
Looking for a job.
We'll do almost anything.
Buy my book.
Murder at the beaver's dam.
When the dam broke, beaver...
Bikel lost his mind.
Oh my god.
Crime and thrillers.
Kidnapping and a kingpin.
Never kidnap a king penguin.
Kingpin on his birthday.
Murder, kidnapping, stalking.
This guy is such a criminal.
Someone is clearly obsessed with detectives.
You can't have a hobby anymore?
Okay, it's just obsession.
Sure.
What do you think of this note?
It's no surprise she's left, is it?
Would you want to work with someone you've dated in the past?
Whoa.
Who would hire me at this age?
No, it's in demand.
Oh, maybe I can be a real estate agent.
Oh my god, so true.
I always wanted to be a rich real estate agent.
Live your dreams, Margaret.
What about you, sussy McSussPants?
Oh, I can't ask you about anything.
Why would Laura recruit you to deal with the theft?
Aren't there any other detectives who are actually qualified for the job?
Wow.
I've been doing very well so far.
If I do say so myself.
The truth will be revealed in the end.
There's only one truth.
Suss, suss, suss, suss.
We'll also be able to go back out.
Wait, where did he go?
Uh, I'm just gonna open this.
Move the painting here.
Yeah.
A safe.
CS00BD.
Customer support is two.
Zero, zero.
Uh, zero?
And birthday.
Do we know his birthday?
Oh, operating office, so one.
Bus driver!
Oh.
Nope.
Wait, no!
We have...
Wait, uh, we have four bus drivers.
Yes!
I did it!
My god!
Oh.
I always wanted to open a ridiculously big safe.
Let's see what secrets he has in here.
Secrets.
Okay, we got some keys.
Keychain.
Server.
Server rope key.
Dear Ingrid.
Wait, this is his handwriting.
I haven't been there for you and the kids recently.
But things are looking up.
I would love to take you to a romantic getaway to Hollandaise.
Love, Manfred.
The handwriting!
Different handwriting.
Demands?
Me, employee of the month?
TV in my room?
Keep quiet about the thing.
Do all these things and nothing will happen to you.
He's being blackmailed!
Oh.
He's being...
Wait, so he...
Is probably being put up to doing the bandit stuff by the penguin, maybe.
Awful lot of security for a branch manager of a bus company.
Uh-huh.
Wait.
This keychain.
Here it is.
The key for the server room.
Yes.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
My bad.
Oh, no.
Wait, should I shut the...
You know what?
Never mind.
It's fine.
It's probably okay.
Oh.
What's this tab?
Maybe Sophie got kidnapped because Blank wanted to...
Oh, no.
Sophie got kidnapped because Sophie wanted to snitch.
Sophie got kidnapped?
There must be more to this.
Yeah.
Dun, dun, dun.
Oh, my gosh.
So crazy.
The story is so crazy now.
Let's go to the server room.
I've been wanting to go in here the whole time.
Let's see what's hidden in here.
Yeah.
What are you doing?
Uh...
Secret detective business.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Don't mind me.
Agatha Minty.
Oh.
Oh, my goodness.
The electrical sparks and blinking lights created a claustrophobic atmosphere.
I don't think they should be sparking.
I definitely felt that I wasn't supposed to be here.
My meeting time?
It's in 45 minutes.
Or 40 minutes.
35 minutes.
I'm okay.
This is his room.
This is the penguin's room.
He got his little TV like he wanted, eh?
Me!
Oh.
Packs under eyes.
Anxious.
I look way worse than I expected to.
Tattered hat.
Poor.
No, no, no.
We're just unassuming.
Just like Columbo.
We wear an ugly, frumpled hat.
And an ugly, frumpled jacket.
Because we want them to think that we're a bad detective.
When we're really smart.
And we're smart.
Breadcrumbs.
Shame.
Those fingernails, man.
He looks like he's been biting them.
Has that been there the whole day?
Oh my gosh.
Duck detective.
I'm watching your Instagram streams.
Thank you.
Okay, let's start here.
What's he keeping in all these boxes?
Books?
Salami?
Why don't you open it up?
I don't think it's meant to do this.
I don't think so either.
Okay.
Oh, hold on.
Honestly, this is nicer than my apartment.
Don't say that.
We'll rough it up a little bit.
Easy.
Bearbus 100 Schmark voucher.
No one use 100...
Now selling for 80 Schmark.
They're using the vouchers.
To get rich.
Bearbus 100 Schmark voucher.
Lisa.
How to delete...
Delete?
How to delete Ize selling history.
Manipulate history.
Confusing message.
Computer illiterate.
Dad, this is not Google.
Camera 03 playback.
CCTV.
What's up with these Bearbus vouchers on Ize?
Oh my goodness.
Whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
So, Rufus blackmailed Manfred to make him stay quiet about...
Is it...
I guess Rufus legally selling lovers.
Vouchers.
Blank is the one that provides the blank to blank.
So, one that provides the...
Oh, Margaret is the one that provides the vouchers to Rufus.
Dun, dun, dun.
So, this is what Rufus and Margaret were doing with the vouchers.
It might be illegal, but this wasn't what I was here for.
I needed to catch the salami bandit.
Yeah.
I quickly needed to find out where Sophie was being kept.
I also couldn't let the salami bandit get away with this.
No.
It was finally time to find out who was behind everything.
Okay.
Oh, Sophie is at...
Who?
Cake?
Sophie is inside the cake.
She's been baked.
Oh, my God.
She's so cool.
The whole office is...
What are you doing in there?
Snooping around, are we?
Oh.
That room is strictly off limits.
I even put up posters.
This is for important detective work.
Yeah.
Stand your ground, detective.
Oh.
I'm just going to...
I'm going to...
Did you kidnap her?
Take winner back?
Was it you?
Hi, man.
I hope you have fun at Ace and Mwah.
That's cool.
Thank you.
Also, Butwise operator.
Welcome to my membership.
Thank you.
Okay.
But he was looking at the CCTV.
Oh, that's cool.
TV.
I wanted to check real quick.
Ducks are named after Sir Geoffrey Duck.
Wow.
Okay, one second.
I think he dropped something.
Oh, did he?
Wait, did he actually?
Did I miss it?
I go check.
No, this is here the whole time.
Let's see the last dialed number on this phone.
I don't know if that has to do with anything.
The number.
But I wanted to talk to what's-his-name first too.
Hello, sir.
What do you think it is?
Have you seen Sophie's resignation?
No.
I can't say it comes as a surprise.
But Hugh wrote the letter.
She never pretended.
I particularly enjoyed her job.
It's difficult finding replacements nowadays, though.
It's not really a detective's job to spin crazy conspiracy theories, is it?
Sometimes the truth is pretty crazy.
Seems a bit cheap.
Cheap added as a clue.
Where are these clues anyway?
Oh no, I'm in the... It's my... You've hit rock bottom.
Go back.
It's my problem, Eugene.
I can only go up from here.
Who am I kidding?
This is so sad.
Yeah, the handwriting is the exact same.
It's all in all three of these.
Okay.
What am I doing?
Oh, the kidnapping.
And the salami bandit.
Blank is the salami bandit because blanks and his environment were blank.
Oh...
Okay, we got two things we got to figure out.
Sophie is at Bear Bus's... maybe... maybe...
What's his name?
Manfred's office in... wait, huh?
Oh, in a... oh, wait, where would she be?
In a box.
We have all things we need, apparently.
Apparently, yes, we do.
Everything to solve the case and everything.
Is she in the... is she in the cake?
No way, that'd be crazy.
She's in a box.
Just a box, everybody.
Wait, unless she's in...
Rufus's office in a box.
Dang.
Well, he even was just like, what's in these boxes?
Unless she's in...
Is she on the bus?
Did he take her to the bus?
Oh!
Bear Bus's office?
Oh my god!
That's where she is being kept!
She's in a fight!
It's important that I stayed calm now.
She's in a fight with... with her... with... for her life!
I couldn't alert the culprit.
Or all of it.
This will have been for nothing.
I needed to first figure out who is behind everything.
So I could confront them.
Yeah, I thought it might be the bus because he's out here.
So I figured maybe he took her to the bus.
The most trendy duck hairstyle is a mullet.
Nice.
And also, this is closed now.
So, um...
Hey, you.
Salami Bandit.
Manfred is the Salami Bandit because...
Maybe Rufus and his...
Whoa, there's so much hair.
Oh wait, because, uh...
Because the Salami Bandits and his handwriting are identical.
Yeah!
Manfred is the Salami Bandit!
Rafalga!
Welcome to Banbusha!
Thank you!
That makes a lot of sense.
Wait.
Oh, thank you for the raid!
Call me!
Sorry, I have to, like, lean in super far to be able to read the raid messages now.
Thanks for the clown raid!
Thank you, thank you!
Hope you had a fun stream.
Honk, honk!
I'm just at the end of the game.
So, if you guys...
If you were gonna play...
If you were gonna...
If you were gonna play it...
Maybe don't...
Don't watch.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ironic.
That is hand written note.
That's meant to frame Fredersen.
Oh, uh, paperbacks thanks to the five gifted!
And versticks for the five gifted.
Ended up incriminating Manfred instead.
Dun dun dun!
Something was missing here.
Who else was involved with this?
I had collected everything I needed.
Hm.
I just had to organize my thoughts.
Ok.
Uh...
Okay, so maybe... that's why she got kidnapped because Boris was in on it and that's why she was like, I'm gonna come clean.
The murdering!
The importing.
God, I wish.
The slimy bandit wasn't working alone.
No.
It made sense for the bus driver to be involved.
Yeah.
Oh, there's more?
Infatuation?
He used to date... wait.
Boris is the accomplice because he used to date... Sophie.
And the slimy bandit needed someone who could convince someone into murdering.
Wait a second.
The infatuation.
Tensai minto.
Don't say that.
After what happened earlier.
He used to date Sophie.
Boris used to date... but why would he be an accomplice?
He needed to convince Sophie into dating.
What does that mean?
No.
Into helping?
Or...
Convince her to snitch... oh, selling.
Wait!
Who would be... oh, maybe... oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, no.
Hmm...
Three or more things are wrong.
I thought maybe he would get her in on it.
Like, hey...
Like, hey, Sophie, we need a third person in here.
Switch Boris and Sophie?
Oh, maybe.
Boris...
No.
Wait, no.
Enemy.
Sophie is the slimy bandit's enemy.
So Boris is the slimy bandit's accomplice because he used to date Sophie and the slimy bandit needed someone...
How?
Boris dates Boris... Sophie dates Sophie.
Maybe you're thinking about it wrong.
Maybe accomplice is wrong.
You read her phone.
Yeah, and on the phone...
Oh, wait...
He...
Oh, no.
Uh...
Here said, I'll tell them everything.
Don't.
And then she blocks them.
Right?
They were dating.
It has to be Boris and... about Sophie and Boris because they're the only ones that were dating.
Pretty sure Penguin Man and Margaret are still... still a thing.
Thank you so much for playing and enjoying the game.
My name...
My name is Deshawn Ricks and I voice Man for the Bear.
Oh, my God.
Thank you for dropping by.
It's so much fun.
And everybody's voice acting is so wonderful.
Thank you.
Oh, sorry if I'm like...
I just kind of...
Well, you know...
You're...
I think I'm about to arrest you, maybe.
But, you know...
You're...
Thank you for dropping by.
Everybody thinks they're the five gifted.
But I'm a little stupid right now.
Don't watch.
Oh, let's see.
I had a hair on my mic and I was like, it's tickling my face.
I'm really glad it's not a spider.
It was a hair on my mic.
How did I get there?
Um...
What do you mean gross?
It's just a hair.
It's my own hair.
I think it fell off my head.
Oh, gosh.
I'm balding.
Anyway, what was it?
Okay.
Let's see.
Boris is the salami...
Or Blank is the salami bandits...
Not lover.
Accomplice...
Because he used to date Sophie.
And the salami bandit needed someone who could convince...
The duck detective.
But I have three or more things wrong.
So close but so far.
Would it be that she's an accomplice then?
Sophie is an accomplice because she used to date Boris.
And needed someone who could convince...
I don't think it's the...
Oh, wait.
No.
Convince someone else, maybe.
Salami bandit needed someone who could convince...
Into selling?
No.
Convince...
Boris into selling?
Well, he...
Oh, into helping.
I feel like helping and selling are like...
I couldn't believe...
Sophie managed to talk Boris into this.
I feel like helping and selling are...
Are pretty close.
So it was...
Between one of them.
Aha!
I had it all figured out now.
It was time that I confront the culprits.
Time to confront.
But first...
More?
I had to free Sophie.
Sophie, I'm coming for you.
Oh, there she is.
Exactly where I...
Oh.
Sophie!
What's going on out here?
They're all in on it, including Freddie.
Why is everyone yelling?
This looks dramatic.
Bum bum bum.
It's...
Kind of a long story.
You're very nonchalant for someone who was kidnapped and has participated in illegal activities, Missy.
And guess who deduced said long story?
Me!
The one and only...
Sophie!
Duck Detective!
Read the room.
Oh my god.
This is how everything went down.
The Bretzel Bearbus branch was suffering losses and had their budget cut as a result.
Uh oh.
Manfred, worried about the financial stability of his family, felt himself backed into a corner.
Oh my god.
This is when he became...
The Salon!
The salami bandit!
He made his grand plan of salami smuggling and realized he couldn't do this alone.
Dun dun.
He recruited Boris, since it would be easiest for the bus driver...
Right, right.
To load and unload the wares discreetly.
Discreetly.
The bus would go through a customs check at the Salsiccia bus station first.
Uh huh.
And then, Boris would take a detour to get the salami and load it onto the bus.
Dun dun dun.
This is why the buses always had a huge delay.
Mmmmm.
It wouldn't be easy to talk Boris into crime, so Manfred convinced Sophie to join the team.
That's so messed up!
Boris's obsession with her would make it easy for her to manipulate him into helping with the plan.
That's so sad.
How good do the illegal salamis taste?
Everything was going well until...
The Duck Detective!
Mets me.
Infiltrated the office.
Yeah.
Freddie was meant to be the skeeter.
The Duck Detective!
Manfred was the secret code for the crime.
But I'm not fooled that easily.
Nope.
Sophie began getting cold feet and ultimately wanted to confess to the police.
But who called the Duck?
It was Laura!
Manfred couldn't have this so he interfered.
Laura called so that she could figure out who stole her lunch.
In an outburst of panic he abducted her and hid her in the luggage compartment of one of the buses.
Wowee.
And this is why Manfred stole the Duck Detective!
Dun dun dun!
Why would you do that though?
Oh, is it to get Freddy fired, I guess?
Wait, we get to choose?
Time to frame Freddy.
Should we arrest Freddy anyway?
I
kind of want to say no.
I kind of want to take Freddy downtown.
Remember, he was blackmailed.
That's right.
He was blackmailed by a certain penguin.
But, he technically didn't get his hands dirty.
Not to mention what it would do to his poor family.
Wait, he did get his hands... wait a second.
Yeah, that's... I mean, if you organize a murder, you still...
Just because he didn't commit the murder...
What about Sophie?
Without her, the smuggling wouldn't have been possible.
She manipulated poor Boris into taking this lobby across the border.
He kidnapped a woman.
Wait, do we get to choose forever?
Should Sophie get arrested?
Oh, we can see who gets...
We can say who gets arrested or not.
I feel like Sophie should get arrested.
I feel bad for poor Boris who got manipulated into this.
I think we should arrest Sophie.
And that's what they want you to think.
Maybe.
On her birthday?
She can watch KTS from jail.
What she did was clearly illegal.
Yeah!
She needs to face the consequences.
Boris was at the end of the chain.
Had he refused to take the salami on board, the plan would have not worked out.
Should Boris get arrested?
No!
Maybe.
He didn't even realize what was happening.
I think he did.
I don't think he's that dumb.
Maybe he is, I don't know.
All right, I've made up my mind.
Wait, what about the penguin, though?
I will report to the state police.
Wait, we're only arresting Sophie?
This is so backwards.
Only arrest the person who was kidnapped.
The only person who wanted to turn themselves in.
Sophie!
What is this?
If I had known that calling the duck detective would result in this, I would have never done it.
You were supposed to find out who stole my lunch.
I did, I told you.
Maybe she's my best friend of smuggling.
I did, I did do, I did do that.
Oh no, she's crying again.
I knew this was a bad idea from the beginning.
This is so ducked up.
Why did Boris have to lose the bag?
Uh oh.
My God, he is such an idiot!
I had no idea it was that important.
Why didn't anyone tell me about the plan?
See, he didn't know.
You said your cousin was ill.
And the only thing that would make her happy was the sausage salamis.
I should have known.
If you're stupid enough to believe that...
You know what?
Yeah, jail for Sophie!
Jail, jail, jail!
Then, you're also too stupid to bring a couple sausages across the border.
You know what?
I don't, I don't...
Jail, jail, jail!
You only let the bear off because he's here right now?
No!
Wow, you really did quack the case, Mr. Duck Detective.
Why do you have to say it like that?
You're just as cool as I imagined.
Oh, he liked it.
Okay.
What now, Fredersen?
I quacked the case!
Solved the mystery of the secret salami!
I got an achievement!
The truth...
Is an ugly mistress.
But it is my duty...
Oh my god!
Manfred was in the back smiling about it!
...of Lady Justice.
I'm the 2%!
I can't!
Oh my god!
Oh
god, my meeting is in 8 minutes!
Hold on, I think they're messaging me.
Oh gosh!
I can't believe I won!
This was probably 99% before this run.
2%!
It is the mint way, alright!
I can't believe...
We are so vastly wrong!
Oh my gosh!
My ways are unconventional, everybody!
My Oshii is in the 2%!
Well, you know what?
Probably!
Probably any other playthrough you'll watch...
Has Manfred getting arrested.
So, our playthrough...
Is unique!
The vibe!
Oh gosh!
Thank you for ducking!
Good time, Eugene!
Might not be a Columbo, but...
He's still a good egg!
Oh my goodness!
I love you so much!
The real free thinker, right?
I'm gonna recommend this...
Just to test...
I can't believe...
Nothing happened to him!
Oh gosh!
I'm crying!
This is why we love you so much!
I don't know why you're like this...
But please never change!
I think it was the fact that it was so overwhelmingly...
If it were like...
Even 90%, I don't think I would feel so...
But the fact that it's 98% is insane!
One more thing!
Oh gosh!
Crap!
Also, shout out to all the voice actors and actresses...
They did amazing!
I completely forgot to collect my payment from Laura!
Oh no!
Everybody already went home!
Wait!
We can't...
We don't have...
How am I going to pay for the bus?
Oh no!
Guess I'm walking home!
Here I go!
Oh Freddy!
Ahem!
Need a ride?
I just booked this one!
It's been such a long day after all!
Nobody else doesn't like my Kamiyoshi!
Oh no!
No!
Thank you!
If Freddy knows where we live, he'll definitely stalk us!
Come on!
It'll be fun!
Plus, you must be tired after all the detective work!
I wonder if there will be a sequel and Freddy will be our assistant in the sequel?
I really don't!
Please?
Yeah, fine!
I'm sure even the VA in the chat couldn't believe he walked!
Great!
Now I finally have time to tell you all about my ideas for your social media!
Oh no!
Please don't!
Hahaha!
I could get you tons of publicity!
Oh yeah, Freddy my manager!
Just really need an L.A.
Noire playthrough now, please, please!
Usually when I play games like that, people get mad at me in the comments.
They're just like, why is she doing everything wrong?
Why is she such a villain?
And I'm like, don't give me the option to be the villain if you don't want me to be the villain!
Hahaha!
No...
And imagine, we can team up!
Absolutely not.
And I can be your sidekick!
Aww...
Freddy is kind of cute.
I know, I'm a VTuber.
Oh man...
The end!
Yippee!
Just in time for my meeting, perfect.
I have to pee so bad.
This is so bad though.
Oh my gosh, I've had to pee for like the past half hour.
Thank you guys for joining me for Duck Detective!
If there's a sequel, I will play it.
This is so much fun.
I'm sorry for kind of skewing the polls a little bit in terms of Manfred walking free, but it was great.
Baldur's Gate 3 evil playthrough.
I would do something like that, but I think Baldur's Gate is just way too long.
But yeah, I really thought something was going to happen to the penguin and the sheep lady, but nothing.
I guess, you know, justice can't always be served.
I didn't know my Oshi was a bad girl.
I would stick around and talk more with you guys, but I really gotta go.
So thank you so much for joining me today, even though I was a little late.
A little silly, but...
I'm sorry I was so stupid during that one part.
But...
We got the rest of it.
I got the rest of it.
With my big brain.
I just took a...
There was like a...
There was a salami stuck in my brain cogs, okay?
Anyway...
Thank you guys!
Have a great night.
Oh!
I can show you...
Tomorrow!
Tomorrow...
I did make a schedule.
I gotta post it.
I will post it after my meeting, most likely.
I think this is going to be really big.
Oh!
No, it's perfect size.
So tomorrow...
I will be doing a VR chat stream.
So...
I will be hanging out in VR.
I'll be in full body VR.
So you can see me wiggle and squiggle.
And so we'll do that tomorrow.
And then afterwards, we'll be off Kai.
And then as of Sunday, I'll be heading off to Japan.
So my schedule will be a little inconsistent.
From Sunday.
But I will be still streaming from Japan.
That is the plan.
I bought a bunch of stuff for it.
So...
Oh!
And tomorrow, I will be doing a test stream of my laptop.
And hopefully everything will work out.
I love you.
Please never change.
Thank you.
Thank you guys so much.
I will see you tomorrow for a wiggly squiggly time.
And yeah!
Otsumito!
Otsubustin.
Otsu Dark Detective!
Thank you guys.
Thank you so much!
This was so much fun!
Bye bye.
See you.
Bye!